Well, good afternoon. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's. We're going to talk about cancer therapies for home use. So these are things that would be particularly things done in the home. These are obviously not all inclusive, but these are some of our favorites that we use in a home and how they into relate
Because that's the question we want to hit. Most importantly, today, obviously, are by favorite therapy is the right machine. And you're either using the true right like this or the TV 4000 those really two that we really recommend at all.
This is, I don't know if that's an F-22 or F-117, this some bulb on the little bulb on the right is just a grown bulb. We don't use that. They just have it in here on the picture.
But how about runtime and program use with the right. So obviously all of our patients are using the program that we wrote for them for overnight use.
But can you overdo the right. Can you use it too much? Is there is there a chance that you could overdo your right time.
With cancer, my answer is no, with with live disease, the answer is yes, obviously, because it could kill too fast.
Well, you're talking about a bacteria with, especially with lipopolysaccharides in the membrane, you could end up causing a hurt cyber reaction with cancer, you don't get that.
So you cannot rife too much. As I was explaining to somebody in the office today, how much do I rife. So what I met the office I'm here Monday through Thursday, typically, I'll typically run the rife while I'm here at my desk in our two hours, maybe even three hours on any given day today.
I didn't do it at all. I was too busy at an time to do it. But most days, so I'd say two to three days a week. I'm running the rife while I'm in the office. I get in the office between seven, seven, seven, seven, 30 every morning.
And I leave here about five ish, six ish, seven ish, whatever, at night. What I go home, I'm using the rife, obviously, in my program overnight.
But I actually wrote myself a longer program, 11 hour program. So because I get rife time as soon as I'm sitting down, we're watching TV or we're doing something like that, I'm running the rife. So I'm getting a lot of rife time.
And I think the more the merrier, I think, quite honestly, it's only by the grace of God that I'm still here, but it's really by the grace of God that he's given me the wisdom of the rife machine that I'm still here.
And I'll say that with no apologies, because it's really that's what's I think the biggest thing that's made the change in my with my cancer.
So I get as much rife time as possible. If I'm feeling worse, because with my symptoms, I tend to go in a roller coasters. So I might have two really good weeks. Then I'll just kind of go downhill for a couple weeks.
When I went my lower end of the roller coaster, I'm usually the rife more often. I'll come in and sit down on a Saturday to the rife on.
And I'll be anytime I'm sitting down at home, I'm running the rife. If I'm in the low side of the roller coaster at work, then I'm for sure running the rife at work. And sometimes a load day, I could run it for five, six hours during the day.
So if I'm feeling worse, I'm doing more rife time.
And the program use, if we did not make a day program for you, you run the night program again during the day. So let's say you're only going to do it for two hours is running for two hours.
For instance, with my at home, I may sit down on a Saturday, because I'm going to watch a little bit of college football or something, and I turn the rife on.
But then I get up because I have to go do something. I typically don't turn it off. I'll come back three hours later, and I'll just put them all on my belly again.
So I run my rife hard, you could say. It could be running some days, it could literally be running in the weekends, 20 hours a day. I might probably be sitting, getting 11 hours total rife time, but I'm really the machines running a lot.
So I have no qualms about doing that.
I am pro wave is another instrument that you could use, of course, attached to the rife, and that could help with detoxification, but it is a way to get some higher frequencies in your body that the true rife can tolerate through the ball.
So using the foot bath, you could get some higher frequencies, and that's one of the biggest benefits of the pro wave.
Now, everybody wants to see what it's pulling out of their body and how the water changes, and there is truth to that that it does pull stuff out of your body, and you are detoxified, but that's not really the key point of using the ion pro wave.
And then I am pro wave is getting different frequencies in your body that you can't use the ball for so you're using higher frequencies, typically with that with that I am pro wave.
Is there something detoxification that will take place? Yes, is the change of color of the water, a crucial thing that your this is when I'm pulling out of my body.
And I've written some blog posts about that when I was first, you could take the ion pro wave, okay, I tend to be a skeptic.
So you take that pro wave, throw it in the water, and turn it on, run it on the program, but you're going to have some tanish color in the water because it is ionizing some of the minerals that are in the water, depending on your water, you're going to have some different colors.
So you're not going to get the nearly the same amount as if you had your feet in that path too, so you are getting some pole and some changes and some detoxification through your feet, but don't get to hung up on the color of the water or the gunkiness of the water, don't get to hung up on that, that is not the primary purpose of the ion pro wave.
Just, I know we all want to think, oh, I'm pulling out this and I'm pulling out this one, there's some truth to that, there's a lot of truth to that, but don't get to hung up on that, that's not the main purpose.
Of course, you don't do the ion pro wave the same time you're doing the ball, so there really is no correlation there.
Can you do the ion pro wave while you're doing some of these other therapies? Well, let's talk about some of the other therapies we'll talk about those.
So one thing we have a lot of patients doing is these infrared heating pads, now there's several different types of infrared heating pads out on the market, this is one that we push it's got like little jade.
Stodes on it to help disperse that infrared heat, it's those are nice little heating pads, there's other people that have some ones with amethyst crystals in them, can't remember the name of all those different ones are some that are larger pad that you can lay on, there's a lot of different ones on the market, they're all good.
I would not say they're good for killing cancer, they're not good for that kind of thing, but they're good for helping with the symptoms, it can really help you feel better.
And it can decrease pain sometimes, but it is a heat source, so some people do much better with an infrared heat pad, it can really help deliver detoxify if you put it over your liver, put it on your back, it can really give a lot of comfort.
Some people do poorly with the infrared heat pad causes a little bit increase inflammation because of the heat and it can actually increase pain so everybody's a little bit different.
I use this I use this exact same pad right here so I pull this picture up in the in the winter typically on my chair here at work right now it's actually sitting by the side of my desk because I don't use it in the summer.
And there's times that it really gives me comfort makes me feel better there's times that I feel like I get a little more sore afterwards.
Somebody asked a question about using the infrared heat pad while they're doing the coffee in a model, use the coffee in a while they're waiting and arrested and allowing the coffee to help stimulate that Vegas nerve.
So that's all that's all find you can do that that can be beneficial.
It just depends on, you know, your situation and how you got your your house set up to do that.
It could be benefit to using a heat pad while you're doing the coffee and I'm sure there can be because that can just help again that flow the blood flow to deliver the bio flow from the liver down the common bio duct and help that and help with your gallbladder flushing so there could be some real good benefits to coupling up these therapies.
Another home therapy is the PEMF of course this one is not the same one we use at home using the office because the ones that we have for the office are just not cost effective there is too expensive for most people to have at home.
But a home type PMF this one is similar little bit different than the one we typically recommend I just couldn't grab a picture of that real quick.
They're really great devices now there's some I am arrests and deeper devices out there that are the low frequency ones and there's the little bit higher actually the home ones are more medium frequency ones that we sell there they can be great machines to use now can you couple them with the heating pad yes you can can you couple them with the right.
Yes, you can so I have a home PEMF at home I don't use it as frequently as I used to but definitely I would have my right Friday in the same time you have the PEMF running absolutely can you use the PEMF while you're using the I and cleanse absolutely you can do that as well so again the only.
Contra education to the PEMF is if have any internal electrical device like a pacemaker or something like that.
But certainly you could use the PEMF correlated with any other device there's no issues with that H bot so H bot hyperbaric therapy is a great home device to that we have several patients that have an H bot this is one that is a real common one that they have at home.
It's smaller than the one we have at the clinic.
Can you couple it with other therapies no you can't because you can't get a cord in there for to get your bulb in there could you run the right outside of the H bot like right here or set it on top of the window up there certainly you can.
You're going to be about two feet away from it but that's just fine you could I would certainly you're running this H bot for an hour I turn your right but the ball right next to it if it's in the same location in the same room.
For sure I do the right while I do the H bot the frequencies will still penetrate right through that wall of the H bot get into your body so it's still going to be a benefit of course it's going to be two three feet away so it's going to be less benefit but still you're slay there for an hour you might as well do it.
So time use on the H bot you really need to use the H bot typically an hour to two hours each session and the frequency for cancer patients should be at least three times a week at least if you have an H bot at home you should be doing it every day if it all possible it's a day skip those busy days which you should shoot for trying to do it every day.
That's the benefit of the H bot there's just a lot of studies on that coffee animals at home.
Obviously use time you're when you first start doing coffee enemies you might only be able to hold it for 30 seconds to two minutes your goal is to hold it for 10 to 20 minutes that would be a good goal and doing the coffee animals.
Some people never get up to that time don't beat yourself up you're still getting stimulation of the vagal nerve doing it just even for 30 seconds you're getting stimulation of the vagal nerve and that's really the goal you don't you know the longer you hold it the better there's argument to that the longer you hold it you will probably absorb more of the coffee.
And that's it brings up another question I know Michelle has touched on this multiple times to but the longer you hold a coffee in the more you will absorb especially if you're more dehydrated so if you drink you make sure you keep your water intake up if you're doing coffee animals frequency on coffee animals we have some people that are doing them once a week we have some people doing them several times a week.
We have a lot of people that are doing them every day you're doing a full true gertian type protocol which we don't have anybody doing a full version protocol that's you're doing coffee animals three to five times a day.
We don't have anybody doing that right now but doing coffee animals can help with the pain so that's one of the tend to forget to touch on when we talk about dealing with cancer pain many times people do coffee animals that can really help lower the pain.
Is many components of pain and one can be an increase in sympathetic tone so that is one of the huge benefits of a coffee animal is decreasing sympathetic tone because it stimulates the vagus nerve and that is your parasympathetic supply so that will help call parasympathetic overtone and stimulate those parasympathetics through the vagal nerve.
Also one of the reasons why coffee animals can help with pain is that it can help flush the colon and that can be a reason for pain if you have any colon distension you have distension of the intestines or blockage in the intestines anyway that's why you really really do not want to be constipated at all no matter what and certainly if you have cancer.
So frequency can be multiple times a day especially if you're dealing with some pain or dealing with any colon issues you can do multiple coffee animals a day make sure you drink in lots of water though.
And correlation with other therapies and coupling with other therapies if you're holding your coffee animals for 15, 20, 30 minutes and you certainly can go lay in your bed and do P E M F or heat or rife.
And then the last one home therapy that people are doing home is a sauna I put a picture of our solo soda system but there's all sorts of different soda systems out there use time again you start with about five minutes of time if you're just due to sauna you have to get used to it have your body get used to it.
For about five minutes you move up to 10 minutes where you can tolerate that you have 15 minutes you can tolerate that there's some people that they don't start sweating until 15 to 20 minutes into the soda but even at that you want to go to your own tolerance.
So you start out in five minutes at a time maybe that's all you could really take right now even though you didn't even start sweating the ideas you have to build up to that take some getting used to.
Frequency you can do a sauna every day if you're and then some of the things that you want a couple with the sauna is making sure that you're getting minerals if you're sweating a lot.
So if you're doing a sauna every day but you're hardly sweating you're just a little clammy and you go take a shower you're not going to really need to have to supplement with any extra minerals.
But if you're doing a sauna every day and you are sweating like a stuck pig well then you better make sure you're adding some minerals supplementation to your diet as well even if your diet is good you don't want to end up be low in minerals and then and then just losing all your water so you need to keep your electrolyte levels up.
I know I do a sauna and I feel so much better when I do a sauna so can you couple the sauna with anything yeah you can certainly have the right going on when you have a sauna.
You don't you really wouldn't be able to couple anything else with the sauna but definitely the right could be coupled with the sauna.
Personally, I don't do that because where my sauna is it's not near the rife and I'm not moving it but so but the sauna is another great home therapy to use.
Okay, I will open it up and unmute everybody and you're all live so if you have any questions now is the time to speak up or wherever hold our piece.
This is Dottie and I had a question something told me that almonds from the USA are washed with polypropylene or something they use in that out of the acid so not by almonds from USA but to buy them from Mexico have you heard of that.
So question is are almonds from the USA washed with polypropylene or poly ethanol or some toxic substance and you shouldn't buy almonds.
I did hear that a while back several months ago ago I you know I don't I haven't I don't know if it's completely true.
I don't know if it's from different almond farms I don't I don't know that I can verify that you know this is the struggle that we get with most of our food products.
You know all much of them have poisons and you know GMOs even if they say no GMOs it's just it's it's a very it's a very difficult subject because we just there's so much that we just don't know.
We can trust a company and trust a food product and then we can be completely misled so yeah that is difficult I mean I would you know I honestly I mean I am I lived in Mexico and I there's lots of things about the trustworthy does some of their products coming out of there then I would be cautious about as well.
So it is hard and some of these things you can you can soak like with with all the nuts if you soak them overnight that can help with some issues that are on the surface but if there's anything that is that there's the trees are sprayed with or your product any other food product is sprayed with or that soil.
Because of previous trades well it's going to be in the cellular structure of the products will be impossible to wash it out so yeah it's a it's a difficult thing we when we buy almonds I just buy the almonds the standard almonds.
That are out there but it gets to what you're dealing with food products like that you kind of got to pick your battles you know you do your best and you just you do your best and you got to trust God.
Thank you. I have another question and it's about SCAC T which I am drinking is it before I eat or after and we're making it the way you're supposed to but would it be better to buy the SCAC T concentrate that you have.
And use that instead of making our own and we would it be more effective no I don't think it'd be any more effective the the T type SCAC that you make is just as good as the concentrate tends to be a little less expensive I believe as well.
The only thing that I would say about the SCAC is that you're make sure that you're you're taking it on more of an empty stomach.
And the way that Renee used to teach how to drink the test SCAC is to sip it like a tea.
So that you just get the slow image of it over the course of about 30 minutes.
Okay, thank you.
Dr. Connors, this is Janet Hitzling.
Hello.
Hi.
I have been having problems with eight two.
And when I was there at the clinic I had two malgum fillings I needed to get out which I did do that.
Yep.
And then I had a root canal and it suggested I wait to have that removed.
I haven't had that removed, but this tooth is a totally different tooth that was not in the picture at all.
And it just flared up all of a sudden and really with that has been bothering me.
So do you already have a feeling of that tooth?
Yes.
I did go to my biological dentist last Thursday.
It started bothering me Wednesday.
My Thursday was quite bad.
And he, first of all, we thought it was a tooth that had a crown on it.
But he did an x-ray because we didn't have a good x-ray on it.
Really, he said, I really can't see anything that's alarming to me.
So why don't you go home and do lots of salt water.
And I told him about the tooth miracle oil that I had from you.
And he said, do that.
So I did all those things.
And then he had a little better.
But then I thought about the right and I looked up on programs for the dental.
It's sort of a dental infections.
Yep.
And so Sunday, I mean, there was really good information on there.
So they said to run that this program three times back to back, which I did for so for three hours Sunday.
Then Monday and Tuesday, I did it.
I ran it for at least three hours.
And it's a lot better.
It's not totally gone, but it's a lot better and it's still doing salt water and all of that.
So my question is, can I do too much of the right?
You just said you can't do too much of the right.
Okay, can I do too much about when I'm running programs like that?
And then also trying to run the cancer programs.
Okay, so the answer to that question is no, you can't do too much.
The the deeper answer to tooth issues is that will if I have if I have a cavity will running any of the right programs solve the problem of the cavity.
No.
So, but if I have a tooth that's bothering me and I think I have a cavity, you go get an x-ray and the dentist is good.
The dentist is like, I don't know, I don't think it's a cavity.
Then it's quite possibly an infection.
And then running those infection programs.
And I would recommend that you do run the dental infection programs on the right.
If you're not getting any relief from that, don't feel bad about running the viral program, the viral complex program.
Or we're talking about a biotoxin in your tooth.
We don't know if it's bacterial or it's fungus or it's viral.
So, run the viral complex program, run the fungal programs and go to the bacterial programs too.
That of them say dental on them.
But you just want to make sure you're you're hitting the frequencies that are going to be specific to that infection.
If it is an infection, if it is an infection.
So, you cannot run too many of those programs.
So, you cannot hurt yourself, running too many of those programs.
If it's not an infection and it just is a cavity and it's, you know, just literally air or saliva that's.
Dip it at that nerve because the cavity is as deep as a nerve root.
The cavity would hurt.
The right programs are going to help.
So, you have to get a fill in, you have to get that corrected by the dentist.
So, they did look at that.
And the feeling that's there, I just actually had it filled, not that long ago, maybe within the last year.
So, by a different dental, a different dentist that I've quit going to.
I think they said it's very close to the nerve, which could be the reason why I'm having problems.
Yes, it could be because you might underneath that feeling.
If they didn't do a good job of getting it stuffed in there, you could have a little bit of a cavity still and you could have.
Remember, your teeth are.
You know, they're not this solid material.
If you look at it under a microscope, your teeth have all these little, little crack, a little, um, canals in them.
And, you know, they're a porous structure like a bone.
And bacteria could get in there and could be hiding underneath that feeling and could be continuing to road away.
And that's what's hitting that nerve.
Well, if you use the knife to kill that, the bacteria, that is really good.
But that doesn't mean it's going to, it's going to stay gone.
So you more bacteria are going to get in there as you eat something else tomorrow for supper.
And you still may need to get that filling popped out drilled out and refixed.
But if it is all the way down to the nerve, they might say, oh boy, this is, we're going to have to do a root canal.
Then we need to have another discussion.
Yeah, well, I'm done with root canals.
Okay.
I'm done with them.
I'll just have the tooth pulled. I don't like that idea, but that's why I'm thinking I'm trying to save it if I can.
Yeah.
So, all right. So, um, so I'm feeling today.
I'm feeling just kind of run down again and almost like fatigued and a little bit shaky.
So that's, I would get to feeling this way when I was back several months ago, when I was doing so much rife.
And then I have a beamer and I was doing too much of the rife, but you don't think that how I'm feeling would be caused from.
No, I don't think it's from too much of the rife. I think if anything, it could be because you have this little subclinical infection going on.
So, maybe I just need to think about having it pulled.
Maybe, maybe, but maybe just keep doing what you do.
If the pain does go away, then that could be a good side that may call down.
It is calming down. It's majorly better than it was.
Okay.
And I have one more quick question. Can I have.
So, can I have too many carbs because I'm eating.
I can pick the buckwheat pancakes for breakfast.
And then if I have quinoa or rice and lentils or some potatoes for supper.
Is it too much to have to, I mean, for a long time, I had no carbs in my diet.
And now you've said I could add some.
So, I'm trying to decide if I can, if I'm still doing.
I could do too many of those.
Well, absolutely, we can't be too, too many of those.
So, we're not asking you to count your total grams of carbs at this point.
But if you did, you'd be surprised that you're probably creeping up there.
Sometimes if you get a kind of a check in your spirit about eating too many carbs,
it just might be good to just call it down to kind of do a little meaty carb fast for a couple of days.
Doesn't mean you're cutting about all together, but just kind of way back for a couple of days.
And then slowly go back and sometimes it's good to do that every couple of weeks.
Okay.
And how I just, I was doing so marvelous and for weeks after I got, after being out there, I thought, oh, good.
Now I've been, I've had it last week or so, just not feeling the greatest.
And that's like, okay, I can go through periods of I'm listening to what you just said about yourself.
So, sometimes you'll go through a week or two of not feeling the greatest.
Yeah.
So, I just know that at least in my experience and my experience with dealing with patients for 20, what years is that it can be like a roller coaster.
Yes.
So, you know, quite honestly, and I've told share this on other Zoom calls and with with people in person.
A year ago, this time, I was quite sure I wasn't going to make it till Christmas.
And I was really feeling bad.
And then it was about a week before Christmas, I just started to perk up and feel a little bit better.
And then, and then I felt pretty good through January, February, then March, I kind of went, kind of crashed a little bit, but not like last October.
It's just, it's just kind of like a roller coaster.
It's gotten to the point in the last summer with like my kids or my family, other people, you know, doctors, I know, hey, how are you doing?
I didn't even want to talk about it.
I know.
Yeah.
If I'm feeling really good today, tomorrow, I could feel like, okay, it's over.
So, it's like, I don't even want to talk about it anymore. Don't even ask me.
I just, I just tell everybody I feel doing great now, whether I'm feeling lousy or not, because it's like, okay, I'm just going to be doing great.
I'm not going to talk about the city works, doesn't help.
So, I just over that piece.
So just, sometimes you just kind of got to get over micromanaging how you feel.
Yeah.
And how do we know when we should get back out there to see you or be rechecked?
And how do we know when that's the time?
That's a good question.
I mean, people that are close to us, it's easy.
It's an easy question to answer.
And why everybody would want to come to Minnesota in January and February.
I just do that.
Yeah.
It's so clean.
But that's a personal question.
So, you know, it's just a matter of just kind of just pray about it.
And, you know, we're here for you anytime.
So, you know, for sure, if a person feels like they're crashing might be a good time to revisit.
But that's not always the only time.
You know, we have some people that know, you know, come in every, you know,
local people might come in every month to get rechecked or every two months, three months, four months.
We have people that drive, you know, from, you know, south of Chicago up here every three months.
So, everybody's a little bit different with that.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Oh, you're welcome.
Dr. Kahners is a share.
Horuska.
Hi, share.
A couple of things.
I went, I guess I'm going to bounce off her a little bit on the dental work.
What is your best way or what could you do?
Like, you know, I had up or all this dental work done.
And then my dentist, the biological dentist, he really doesn't do anything as far as detox afterwards.
He said, really, that wasn't like he had to take care of that through someone else.
A lot of other ones aren't like that, but he is.
And I know I ran into a lot of trouble afterwards.
After what procedure?
Oh, I had two root canal teeth pulled.
A malgum's taken out.
You know, I just, I had a lot of work done and we did it all in one day.
But it just, you know, I had gotten sick and then I really think that had a lot to do.
Oddly, several weeks ago, I coughed up something because I had laryngitis for 40 days.
I went to a cough and I really think it's all related to my dental work.
Sure.
It can't be.
And, you know, it depends on, you know, even if you have a good biological dentist, there's, you know,
unless you're doing everything without anesthesia,
you're going to have to detox that anesthesia.
You're going to, if they're doing a filling, old filling removal,
if there's going to be some spilled into your system, you have to detox that.
So one of the root canal teeth, it did have a black root on it.
So I was real thankful I got that out.
But what was weird a few weeks ago, and I can't believe I didn't save it.
But I really believe I coughed up a piece of string that's probably been in my throat for months.
Well, that's kind of scary.
Yeah, it was. I mean, he is the rubber dam and everything.
But, but I'm like, I really think that that's, you know, probably where that came from.
And of course, you know, I'm just so thankful I got my voice back.
I was beginning to wonder, you know, now.
Well, there's two ways to detox when you do dental work.
You need chemicals like, you know, anesthesia or heavy metals mercury from fillings or other chemicals from other composite fillings.
You're using a key later.
So a key later, like our key look clear, something with maybe DMSA, ETA in it, other key lady agents.
And the second thing is that, okay, a lot of root canal tooth that was infected and the root was infected, making sure that you're, you're running some of the rife programs or biotoxins or using that tooth and gum oil will help boosting up your immune system with some immune supplements too.
Okay. And I am doing a killer cure, even now.
Okay, good.
Yeah. Okay.
Because I do have more dental work to get done on the lower, it won't be quite as good. I don't have any more root canals, but.
Okay. When you get to the point of doing that, make sure you post on the Facebook page, what you're going to do. And I'll give you some other hits if there's anything.
Oh, okay. Okay. Yeah. I know they want me to come in for a cleaning and.
And then I'm like, man, I'm not really ready. I don't feel I'm ready yet. I don't think I can physically handle it since what happened.
But, but I do want to get the other junk out of my mouth, too.
Right.
That's important.
Okay. Real quick.
I went to physical therapy today for the lymphedema.
And they're going to see if I can get a lympha press at home.
And that's something that will manually work on my arm.
And what is it called?
lympha press.
P-R-E-S-S.
And she said it will be like a sleeve. I'll put my arm in.
And it will gradually pump the lymph for me.
It's like a compression sleeve.
Yeah, it's like a compression sleeve, but it's powerized, you know.
Cool.
Yeah, I thought that was pretty good.
And so hopefully in the next few weeks, I'll get that.
And I'm praising the Lord. I've been 15 days paying free.
That's been pretty awesome.
That's really awesome.
You know, since I was in the ER a few weeks ago.
Yeah, that's really awesome.
Yeah, that's really good.
Sticking with the low histamine diet, which I really haven't figured out.
Really too good. I'm probably eating the best with that.
But blood work, I'm going to redo November 12th, and it'll be read the 26th.
Okay, good. I'll look forward to seeing that.
Yeah, just praying that, you know, those councils start going the other way.
I just remember with a low histamine diet, it's not a matter of not eating histamines.
It's more aware and decreasing that consumption.
Okay, yeah, I've been trying to, I don't know.
It's like I said, it's not been the easiest for me.
I figured I'm like, it's enough to be in a vegan.
No, okay, like everything I was eating.
Right.
It seems like every day, like I really shouldn't have been eating.
But the other thing that has changed is my brain.
And that's been clear now for probably a few weeks.
And I didn't know it was, I didn't know it was foggy.
That's the other stuff is scary thing.
That's scary thing, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, but it's, you know, so I feel like there's a couple things on the positive side.
That's right. We're going to code our blessings, right?
Yes, sir.
That's, I do every day.
Okay.
Another question, another question came in as the question was,
is Italian zero zero flower acceptable for every cancer diet?
I have a friend who's very sensitive to the glue,
so that they could eat Italian zero zero flower.
So that's a, that's a stumper for me, because I don't,
I've never heard of Italian zero zero flower.
I do know other people that are celiacs that were able to eat some European wheat flowers.
That they didn't react to crazy in there.
So I'm not familiar with the Italian zeros or a flower.
I would be, I'd love to know where you get it.
If a person who is celiac or very sensitive to gluten can eat it with no problem,
I would say it's probably fine for a person that we were taking them off for cancer to eat as well.
But I would love to have you post the person who posted this question,
and I'm to have you post on the Facebook page where you get it.
Does that be interesting that as well?
All right.
Well, I think we're going up with our time.
Please don't hesitate to email your questions in.
Please put in the, in the email zoom question.
So that it gets tagged so we can find it.
And we'll try to address that question.
Matter of fact, this whole initial presentation came from a question that so many said then so.
Continue to do that.
And if you think of your questions made week, so you don't have to wait for the zoom call to ask them.
We can address them even more thoroughly.
Thanks for everybody for being on.
And now we will talk to you next week.
Make sure you continue to use the Facebook page.
And we do appreciate your likes on Facebook posts and our chats and then our podcasts.
And make sure you watch the end of the actually show, which is something they just started a few weeks ago.
If you like and share that, that would be great as well.
If you have any good testimonials, please feel free to share that on Facebook as well.
Thanks, everybody.
Love you all.
Be praying for you.
Know that I do pray for you.
Everybody on a daily basis.
And I just am very grateful for all of you.
So thank you very much.
Thanks, Dr. Kronner.
We have you too.
Yes.
Thank you.
All right. Talk to you guys next week.
Bye bye.
Bye.